what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we'll be
talking about everyone's favorite demon
emoticon Mitsuko Commodore from
kimmytanaka aka demon slayer
specifically I will be explaining her
incredibly unique demon powers powers
that no one else in the entire series
possesses and I will reveal the truth
behind Wynette Zuko is sometimes
referred to as the chosen demon demon
Sarah is one of my favorite series going
on right now both the anime and manga
are absolutely incredible so let's get
into it if you enjoy the Demon Slayer
content on this channel and you'd like
to see more you can leave a like to let
me know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification
valve a quick thank you to all of our
anime upper patrons who make videos like
this one possible I will talk more about
patreon at the end of this video but
before that please be advised that this
video will contain manga spoilers I will
be discussing everything we know so far
about Nezzer COEs demon powers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned at the very beginning of Demon
Slayer Nezzer Co is the eldest daughter
of the comedy family a large family that
lives in an isolated mountainous area
the family patriarch tan judo Kamado
died sometime earlier as a result of
illness and so the eldest son of the
common family Tan Jiro is charged with
bringing firewood to the nearest town
and selling it in order to make enough
money for the family to survive one
night while ton Jiro is out selling
firewood and fails to return on time as
a result of a snowstorm but demon
attacks the comedy family when tan Jiro
reaches the house the next morning he
realizes that his entire family has been
slaughtered by a demon except for one
person
Naza KO but as a result of the demon
attack nez Zuko has been turned into a
demon herself at first nez Zuko behaves
wildly and viciously and she almost
kills tan judo but when the water
hashira GU shows up to kill nezu KO taan
Jiro refuses to let the Demon Slayer
kill his sister during the brief battle
between tan jianci you nasgo actually
regains some
her humanity and she puts herself in
danger in order to protect her brother
Tong Jiro from gills attacks Natsu coos
behavior is very different from the
behavior of regular demons so much so
that Gil decides to spare her life
sparing a demon's life is almost unheard
of among the Demon Slayer Corps but GU
senses that there is something special
about mezu KO and so he sends both her
and her brother to his mentor and former
water hashira Sakon ji Oroku ducking
under Oroku Ducky's mentorship tan Jiro
trains to become a Demon Slayer for two
years while Mexico remains asleep for
nearly that entire time while Nez suka
was asleep Oroku ducky used a form of
hypnotic suggestion on Nez Zucco
subconscious in order to negate her
demonic instinct to attack humans
eurocode Aki is able to influence Nez
Zuko so that instead of desiring to
attack humans she feels obligated to
protect them as if they were all part of
her family
demons normally replenish their energy
by devouring humans but unlike the other
demons mezu KO is able to replenish her
energy simply by sleeping and despite
being a demon for several years she has
never consumed a single human which is
in itself a practically unheard of
occurrence in the world of demon slayer
it is important to note that after
becoming a demon Nezu COEs personality
changes and her behavior becomes more
childish she also appears to have lost
her memories or at least a significant
portion of her memories and she is
unable to talk properly at first
although she does make verbal noises now
that we've covered the unique
circumstances surrounding how Nezzer KO
became a demon let's discuss all of her
demonic powers when she first becomes a
demon
nezu ko manifests sharp fang-like teeth
very sharp claw like nails and she gains
superhuman physical strength she is also
able to alter the size of her body and
make herself smaller which allows ton
zero to carry her inside a wooden box on
his back in order to hide her from the
Sun and this is because the one weakness
of every demon is their inability to
make contact with sunlight if demons are
caught out in the sunlight they will
burn up and die much like vampire
in Western supernatural mythology in
order to prevent her from biting a human
in case she has ever momentarily
overcome by demonic instinct or
something along those lines Nez Zuko
carries a piece of bamboo in her mouth
at first whenever nets quiz in a fight
she simply fights using her physical
strength and her sharp nails as a demon
she also has incredible regenerative
abilities so even if she loses an entire
limb in battle she can regrow it very
quickly as she gains more control of her
demonic powers Nezzer ko is also able to
use a blood demon art called blood burst
this technique allows Nezu ko to set her
blood on fire and this fire can be used
offensively to completely burn demons or
in ways such as burning the poison out
of someone's blood as the story
progresses nez Zuko's demonic power also
accelerates rapidly and eventually moves
on begins referring to Nezha KO as the
chosen demon and his primary mission
becomes to devour her and now I will
explain why in chapters 83 and 84 of the
manga we get a glimpse of Nezzer coast
true power when she finds herself in an
especially desperate situation mezu KO
undergoes some form of further demonic
transformation her body becomes covered
in what looked like dark vines and a
horn appears on the right side of her
head when she attains this form Nezzer
KO becomes more wild and demonic she
pretty much goes berserk but her
strength and fighting ability also
skyrocket and she is able to fight
against demons who are normally far
stronger than she is including upper
moons however because this form makes
Nezu ko go berserk she begins to crave
human blood much more than usual and
when she first transforms she nearly
devours a human normally Nezzer KO is
able to resist the allure of human blood
really well and she is even able to
resist san amis incredibly rare mata ji
blood but in the berserk demon form nez
Zuko clearly loses control of her
demonic instincts and this is no joke
because tangelo roku da ki ng you all
promise that if Nezzer KO ever attacks a
human they will commit seppuku
this means the Nezzer KO going berserk
could lead to all three of them being
compelled to take their own
thankfully tan Giro is able to calm
Nezzer cooldown by singing her a lullaby
from their childhood eventually nez Zuko
becomes better at using elements of this
form in battle without completely losing
control and now for the biggest twist in
the story of Nezzer ko and her demonic
power the reason why mezu ko becomes
known as the chosen demon and the reason
why Mouzon changes all of his plans and
makes devouring nez Zuko his top
priority in chapters 1 to 6 and 1 to 7
of the manga naisu Co manages to conquer
the Sun by which I mean she is somehow
able to survive being out in the
sunlight despite the fact that she is a
demon unlike all the previous demons
that we've ever heard of Nezzer Co
develops an immunity to sunlight and is
able to move about freely in the daytime
for centuries Mouzon has been looking
for a demon who is able to conquer the
Sun and when he hears about nez Zuko's
ability to survive sunlight he decides
that nez Zuko is this chosen demon all
his plans change and he immediately
begins to prioritize devouring mezu Co
because he is certain that if he can
devour a demon that can withstand the
Sun he too will be able to walk about
freely in the sunlight mu Suns demonic
abilities allow him to live for
centuries they give him superhuman
strength they made him the master of an
army of demons but there is one thing
that he always deeply resented he always
hated not being able to walk around
freely in the daylight
he has spent centuries looking for a way
to remedy this weakness and to make
himself immune to sunlight he had been
searching for various ways to accomplish
this including attempting to find the
mythical blue spider lily a flower that
he believed would help him conquer the
Sun but now all of his attention is
focused directly on Mitsuko but what
makes Nezha ko so special why is it that
out of all the demons who ever existed
Nezzer ko is the only one who somehow
became immune to the Sun as of right now
there is no confirmed reason but I have
a theory and I will explain that theory
right here
another interesting power that Nezzer ko
has is the ability to use her blood to
set tonzura sword on fire and turn it
red when it becomes red tan Jiro sword
looks just like the red sword
used by the legendary breath of the Sun
user who lived many centuries ago the
breath of the Sun is believed to be the
original and most powerful breath style
and all the other breath styles are
derived from it there are multiple clues
in the story which suggests that
Tangiers family is directly connected to
the breath of the Sun user including the
hanafuda earrings with the Sun symbol
which were said to have been worn by the
breath of the Sun user and a dance of
the fire God a mysterious breath style
that some believe may actually be the
breath of the Sun style itself if this
is true it would mean that the breath of
the Sun has been passed down through
Tundras family for generations through
the dance of the fire God and this could
explain why Nessa Coe is so special for
centuries Nezzer ghost family has had a
direct connection to the breath of the
Sun and it's legendary user and the
secrets of the breath of the Sun have
been passed on through their family it
is likely that after she became a demon
nez Zuko's direct connection to the
breath of the Sun affected her demon
transformation instead of becoming a
normal demon nez Zuko's ancestry somehow
interacted with her newly demonic nature
and so she was different from the start
she was able to resist consuming humans
even humans with rare Medici and
eventually she was able to gain immunity
from sunlight and this makes sense if
any demon would be able to conquer the
Sun it would be a demon with a direct
connection to the breath of the Sun now
I don't know if there is a direct blood
connection between the Commodore family
and the breath of the Sun user or
whether it is simply a connection
through the breath of the Sun technique
itself but it seems to me that as the
last two members of the komiteh family
tangelo and Ezra Co are both the
inheritors of the breath of the Sun
legacy Tangier o sword is the perfect
metaphor for this on his own Tangier o
cannot get his sword to turn red like
the sword of the breath of the Sun user
on his own Tundra sword is just black
but with nez Zuko's help
tonzura sword is able to achieve that
legendary color red and to me that
symbolizes the fact that tangelo cannot
defeat Mouzon on his own in order to
defeat moose on
Tangier and mezu KO will have to work
together
only by working together can they embody
the full legacy of the breath of the Sun
user and ultimately defeat moves on but
that is my personal take from what we've
seen so far in the manga please feel
free to give me your thoughts down in
the comments below why do you think Ned
Zuko was able to conquer the Sun and is
it related to the breath of the Sun
style also who do you think will
ultimately defeat Mouzon Tangier Oh GU
Tangier Onizuka together or will it be
best boys ZENIT's ooh let me know down
below if you enjoy the demon side
content on this channel and you'd like
to see more please leave a like to let
me know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you can be notified every time a new
demon slayer video is uploaded feel free
to follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest demon
slayer news and updates i want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making our videos possible a special
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
king zelgius and on he'll cruise on epic
thank you to all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah
Aloha Adam Maddy Mac makoto-kun and
Keylong and finally at the pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness a tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison and Lord
naksan or disciples of Lord we go
himself if you enjoy our videos and you
think they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon link
in the description even a single dollar
will give you access to our exclusive
patron only discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us bass cowboys
[Music]